[Music]
welcome to the Samuel deeds podcast my
name is Mary Ellen Ferguson I'm an
employment lawyer and I'm also the CEO
of the cultural intelligence group and
I've had the great privilege of
worthless Samuel over the last few weeks
and I could not resist asking him
questions about what Samuel is like as
an employer I hope you enjoy this so
Samuel we all know about your terrific
success as a property investor as an
amazing trainer setting up an incredibly
successful company and I'd like to ask a
few questions about that as employer to
employer what you actually do but before
I do that before we explore you as an
employer what was your first job my
first job as in how I first made money
or my first first ever job so I'd like
to see your perspective as an employee
my first ever job was a paper and write
but my first time I went to a workplace
was cleaning snooker tables at Riley's
in Mosul and how did they treat you as
an employee it was all actually I don't
I didn't feel I didn't feel valued I was
completely I just go in and no one would
really acknowledge me even I'm not
learning about it but and then when I
resigned I thought that they were going
to block oh because you know that's ego
or Thomas right but that's okay
so I was almost just invisible where
they I don't agree with the staff but
the actual person who I reported to yeah
it was just I was just invisible really
and has that shaped do you think the way
that you treat your stuff I think so
yeah I mean the the thing I care more
than anything about is just I love to
tell acknowledge people part of my core
values is just acknowledgement I don't
know if it's because of my time at
Riley's I mean it's not like I was
really wounded by that but yeah I think
it's really important that people feel
valued and that people feel appreciated
so I do and sometimes people might even
feel uncomfortable because I may be
overly do it because I'm just so
bubbling up with love and appreciation
for the guys it's nothing
oh my gosh you know you're so awesome I
really appreciate you coming and so
people might even blow well what the
heck but that is a real core value of
mine is recognition yeah yeah well
you're a very passionate guy and I see
that all the time and you do acknowledge
people all the time the reason I often
ask that question of people is that your
very first job you're very important
you're very young right when you have
your first job you're very impression
about that time you're also very
resilient so you might have cried in
your soup about it but you would have
felt it you'd have felt that lack of
acknowledgement and it's really funny
how you had that very first job lack of
acknowledgement and now you acknowledge
people really really well yeah so it's
kind of an interesting thing yeah what
are your priorities when it comes to and
you look at your staff we're going to
talk about what goes on in the office in
the moment but what are your priorities
when you look at the you've got dozens
of people now working for you when you
look at them if I had to say to you what
was your top priority for them yeah what
would you say my top priorities that
people are doing a job or rather they
really enjoy if I sense that someone's
not happy doing what they're doing it
really bothers me
I just cannot and part of why teaching
my training business is to become
financially free to be able to you know
not have to do a job but I feel like I
want my team and my staff to be there
not because they have to be there and
because they want to be there that for
me is the most important thing that's
not 100% and just because I mean I work
I come to the office I work but I'm
doing it from a position of abundance
because I want to it's a mission I enjoy
it and I want everybody to feel that and
I think that they mostly do that's
extraordinary because that's exactly how
I see that's my priority to you I'm also
an employer and I'm also an employment
lawyer so looking at people in the
workplace what you really want to see
them enjoying their job because they
want to get out of bed in the morning
and actually enjoy the experience I look
forward to their day ahead so I think
that's an amazing I'm so glad that we
share that that same priority what is it
like them to work at some your leads
I've got a few questions for you we're
going to run through them the first
thing I'd love to ask you I know the
answer but of all the lovely people out
there where are your offices so we are
in
to London in Marylebone the vibe in the
officers is just incredible it's lovely
you feel like the center of something
really really important so I know that
you do your courses you travel around
the country and not everything is all
about being in central London but they
are awesome offices yeah and I love
being in London
I love the bus of it and yeah the
offices are a great egg right here
so when see you move didn't you yep I
lived in Litchfield actual offices were
in Wolverhampton Hill and Hall right
which was just in the middle of nowhere
it was a mansion yeah and yes the stuff
probably liked the beautiful entrance up
to the office and stuff but it was just
not poppin it wasn't buzzing if you
wanted to appointments with people every
whatever everything was far away and I
just didn't feel that that fit with our
culture yeah so that was one of the
reasons why we moved inland just because
we wanted to be around people we weren't
about to make an impact and London is
some people call it the capital of the
world really it's one of the most
amazing cities on the planet and we
wanted to be where it's all happening
yeah well it's certainly a buzz on and
energy and you've kind of read my mind
because my next question is what for you
is the company culture because you're
saying it didn't that didn't fit your
culture before where you were before and
now it does for your company culture
better so what is the company culture I
think it's just inspiring people being
empowered being inspired being free and
making an impact I think that's that's
the culture but you can't you can't
impact people when no one's around yeah
apart from the squirrels or than the
writers so being in London where there's
millions of people that live here it's
just easier to empower more people and
also fun energy passion purpose mission
these are all words that I could explain
how and why not just words banded around
but with integral parts of that company
culture yeah and how do you balance up
being free on the one hand and being an
employee on the other because ultimately
as an employee you're not completely
free you're there you're you're working
for an employer yep how do you how do
you balance those two things up yeah
okay I mean of course
people in the company are employees I
mean I'm an I'm an employee I guess
because I'm on time and I'm in a payroll
to the company I don't see myself as an
employee even though I am I know I'm
known as well but I don't actually see I
don't see the staff as employees for me
when I think the word employee it's
almost like like a slave to a job you
know so of course technically people
people here of course we're all
employees to the company so when it
comes to the freedom side of things I
guess
of course there's restrictions and
there's rules and things with with a
life and to have complete freedom you
need rules you need guidelines the fact
that we can drive and we can get from A
to B so which is complete freedom in a
car but if there's no rules you wouldn't
be able to do that because it would be
chaos if it could so I think in our
company yes we're free and people have
freedom and people do what they
hopefully we encourage people to do what
they love and we give people freedom and
flexibility but of course there are
rules like for instance punctuality
we're really red-hot on being on time so
you could say well that's not free but
it is because we it actually is freedom
because well where there's no rules
there is no freedom there's just a
awesome disorder and I've seen that it's
kind of empowering what you do because
what you're saying is we're just all one
big team and it does feel very much like
it's a family culture and so far I'm not
meaning family between you and your
brother working together I'm meaning
that everybody does get together now to
ask in a minute how the day starts that
suddenly is because it's for me that was
novel I've come from very very large
companies where they're not able to do
what you do and I very much hope you
carry on doing what you do but what I do
see is that you're empowering people to
do their jobs to the best of their
abilities and that really is empowering
whilst thinking about the team so I
think the reason you want everybody to
be on time is that you want everybody to
be doing to be helping each other out at
the same time and not to let the team
make down by coming in late right is
that the whole motivation behind that
yeah well I think and also how you do
anything is how you do everything
yeah and and and if you're late for the
office then you're going to be late for
appointment then you're gonna be and
then you just stealing people's time
yeah so it's just it's just not teamwork
no
no absolutely no yeah so I've Tansen
Eisley kind of mentioned what you do
first thing in the morning so can you
tell us what do you do first thing in
the morning we look with the whole team
9:00 a.m. on the dot the whole team from
all the departments come together and
we'll do a dance of some kind or like
this may be a stretch we'll put some
music on and it varies each day but
we'll get the energy flowing we'll move
our bodies around and then we'll people
will go get down in a circle and if
there is a little bit but the essence is
the same we might have a ball and we'll
throw it if someone will say something
about what's been awesome about this
week or what they're most excited about
what they're working on and achievement
of success and then and they'll say it
and then everyone will cheer clap and
then they'll throw the ball to someone
else and then that person will then take
a turn and we'll do that just maybe just
for five minutes and and then we let it
go so we'll do all put our hands in the
middle of the circle or do a wall and
and then it's just anyone having a
everyone will clap and then bang and
then we start the day so it varies a
little bit and the whole thing might
only take five or seven minutes but I
just think energy is so important and if
you are sluggish in your body and
sluggish in your mind
oh that's seven minutes each morning
probably is the difference for some
people between a really high energy
productive day and now you start the day
how you start something's really
important I completely agree and I was
an old cynic I'll be completely honest
with you Sammy when I came the first
time I came into the office I'm taking
on I've been warned about there's a nine
o'clock thing am I going to do am I
gonna stand where can I hide yeah it's a
big circle of people and I'm standing at
the back and all of a sudden you got
some really cool music on and people to
clap when they're doing these little
dance it was like it's like okay let's
just do it and it was amazing the energy
that was that raise and you think people
getting into work people have like an
hour and a half journey our journey
you're battling through the the crowds
of people's when you arrive at where you
can arrive pretty stressed and you're
travelling into London but those seven
minutes just completely blast that all
away and people are just so happy
hugging hugging it out at first I
thought it was you know a bit sort of
hippie-ish and then now completely just
day one realize what fun it wasn't how
it
really energized problem I thought was
absolutely brilliant brilliant do you
operate an open-door policy at work like
dippity staff have access to the Samuel
Leeds himself yeah absolutely yeah 100%
and has it happened by accident or did
you decide no I want my door open I want
people to be able to come and talk to me
about anything at any time I mean I
would never want to lock myself in a
room for my staff and my - there are
team names I'm there to serve them and
work with them of course there's you
know there's respect amongst everybody
and I'll go into their room and ask them
questions and check in and hundred
percent yeah I love how you know
everybody you know the names the latest
recruits you might not have been
involved in the recruitment but you got
for example we have latest recruits in
the finance team and you know their
names and so you do you do and I and I
hope that always carries on so now
you're you're growing you're going to
continue to grow the fact that you just
know everybody's name is just so
impressive and I you take time to say
hello to every single person you come
across it's really impressive I think I
think so ultimately if I'm a jerk you
know then that's not going to make them
feel good about wanting to do a great
job and and we're all on the exact same
team yeah there they are my teammates
yeah and of you know and on there to
serve them yeah and and train and mentor
and support so and in fact sometimes I
have to train them to be to be to feel
more comfortable with approaching me
it's officially new people and of course
there's some things if they don't ask me
everything if someone comes in the
system you know what's the password for
this and all what do I say to this not
everybody reports to me
so it's but-but-but-but for me to be
approachable and people to feel that
they can come and speak with me and ask
my advice on things I think I do you
think it's really bored it is important
but you do go out of your way to talk to
people which i think is really nice to
make them feel like they can approach
you you know you don't you do break the
ice with people which i think is really
lovely what's it like working with your
brother because he's the CEO of the
company right so what's it like working
with your brother I love working with
Russell I think he's an amazing CEO he's
cool calm collected he never gets
stressed out
and he just makes everything happen so
he is incredible he's humble and he lets
me be the frontman I often take a lot of
the glory and no one even knows anything
about what he does
so yeah I mean and if ever we disagree
on something we have this policy which
is the person that wins the argument
decides so if I'm saying hey we should
do this and he said NASA bad idea we
should do this well argue about it and
it's just a person who puts forward the
best argument then we'll just do that
because there's no room for egos there's
no room for personal preferences in in a
growing business it's just a case of
what is best for the business
and that's every decision also a case of
whose Department is so I'm not going to
stick my nose in and start talking about
which computers we should have because
that's just not why that's just not my
bag yeah anybody the same way when it
comes to other things like when it comes
to marketing and media and videos he
wouldn't come in so I feel like we've I
mean we've we've argued for sure but in
an in a debate type way we've never
fallen out ever we've never
he's never been really annoyed with me
oh we've got in a mood or four-eyes it's
just a couple years that we've been
working together has been blissful it
has been fun we're best friends and he's
taking the busines training business and
even even the property business to to
talk to he's made it massively more
successful and so other people as well
as Sarah and other people in the team
but Russell is just incredible so I'm
very blessed and happy that I managed to
persuade him to come into the business a
couple years ago but it's a remarkable
relationship if you don't mind my saying
what she would serve you you do have
discussions and with very healthy
discussions they're not disagreements
and arguments they're discussions and
you respect each other so much that's
the first thing I noticed when I was
watching you because you know we've been
having discussions about all sorts of
things in terms of your growth and
getting you to the next stages and you
really do listen to each other and
you're both really receptive to ideas to
fresh ideas and there isn't about
winning the argument it isn't about
being right it's about doing what's best
of the business and that really shows
when you're talking to your brother
which is which is love and that's rare I
think
sometimes when you're working with your
family it can just be too close but
you've got this very healthy respect for
each other and I think what you're
saying there but having responsibility
for different departments that must be
the key to it as well you don't stick
your noses in each other's there's no so
to speak for sure but also being really
direct and never taking anything
personal so me and Russell we love each
other too bit but we're very direct and
if he thinks I'm being a jerk or if he
thinks I'm wrong he'll just tell me
straight and I think we both do that and
also when we meet up and we talk about
how the business is going
we despite us doing an extremely well in
business and as I mean a massive you
know expansion and success over the last
couple years when we other business
meetings we probably spend ninety
percent of the time not patting
ourselves on the back saying oh we're
doing great don't wait Wow we spend 90%
of the time saying how terrible we are
you know this is wrong this is bad this
could be improved this is and after a
meeting with Russell I'm like man we've
got so much room for improvement and
that's that's the way we have a meeting
so whilst we do celebrate the successes
we definitely are just constantly trying
to improve trying to improve the systems
trying to improve the business the
product the service is the way we invest
our money the way we encourage others to
invest their money we're just trying to
get better and better every day
yeah and I've seen that with my own eyes
you definitely do you're hard on
yourselves you're you are perfectionist
you want to provide the best possible
service if you want to be the best you
only the best which we do want to be you
have to be those people say you're too
hard on yourself
but an athlete has to train hard and has
to be hard on themselves and I think in
business if you want to be the best you
just you have to be hard on yourself so
I don't get down about it
I don't think oh my gosh we're terrible
and then get down about it I'm actually
excited by it because of the room for
growth and speaking of growth it's huge
and your plans for next year and the
year after
absolutely tremendous and they're
massive you're having to recruit people
all the time how do you go about
recruiting people okay so I go off gut
feeling very much and I know within
within usually about a minute whether I
want to hire somebody or not now I'm not
saying I'm the best recruit in the world
I'm
saying all the way I do it is the way to
do it at all it probably isn't but for
me usually what happens is is is I'll
just be able to I don't I don't really
go through CVS I'm not really interested
in qualifications I'm more interested in
the attitude of the person the energy of
the person than anything else you remind
me of a young Richard Branson because
he's very much like that - he's very
much he will hire people on the basis of
the positivity he just wants to work
with positive people it's all about
positivity if you look at the Branson
brand and all of the people that have
worked with him and he's a very positive
person and you're a very positive person
and he surrounds stuff with positive
people you can't go wrong yeah and if
someone's really skilled but they are
another thing to do as well is I'll ask
people you know awesome you know what
happened with your last movie last job
if they say anything negative about
their last job or their last employer oh
I didn't work out because he was lasting
flaw was quite controlling or oh well my
last I just think even if that's
completely true and even if you're being
gracious in how much you downplayed it
just the very fact that you're even
being negative like for me that that's a
real as a real red flag much more than
and I've employed people that have a
degrees and stuff like and they're just
they've just been terrible at it
yep so that their qualifications we
harvest their work talk you know do much
detail but but but honestly I just think
you can train you can try and you can
train anyone to do anything pretty much
within reason of course is thinking if
you can take it on like a full-time
accountant they'll need to be qualified
but if you're taking on someone who's
going to be in customer service or media
some of the guys some of the
videographers they're kind of pretty
much self-taught and I'm not poopoo in
the qualifications and stuff at all but
to me that's definitely secondary so
yeah good feeling and what often happens
as well is I'm not involved in I'm not
involved in a lot of the interviews but
if they're going to be working closely
with me I will be but what would
normally happen is that some of the team
maybe Sarah will do the interviews there
might interview ten people and then when
she's found someone that she thinks I
care I think this
the one then all interview the person
but I'll interview them five minutes
yeah like my PA that I just got Valerie
I don't know how many people sarah had
to interview but she said tell me what
was found Valerie I think you're gonna
really like her she's got this she's got
all these qualifications she's got all
this experience on that and within 60
seconds I was just like yes so it's just
good feeling and intuition speaking of
selecting staff any recruiters stuff
have you got career paths for your staff
within the organization yeah massive
yeah massive I think people need think
people need to be able to have a like a
purpose and personal goals and I'll ask
you know and I don't wanna be talking
like an imperfectly perfect employer
because I'm really not and maybe it'd be
good to talk about some of the things I
struggle with as well maybe I don't know
but I do always take the time to ask the
ask the team especially if I'm working
with them if they're like a media or
something and which is kind of my
department what are your personal goals
where do you want to be in three years
time and really get to know what they
actually want to do and then I'll try
and help figure out a plan of how they
can get there maybe they want to be a
manager or maybe they don't want to be a
manager maybe they want to be like a
specialist and just get paid really well
do something really nice so I think
figuring out what they want and never
assuming because sometimes it might be
easy to think oh this person wants to be
promoted but actually they don't
actually just want more money or this
person wants more money but actually
they don't actually what they want is
they just want recognition so figuring
out what what what people want some
people love to come out to the events
with us and be on the road and for them
that's like it's amazing it's a treat
and other people really don't want to be
they don't like coming to the events
it's gonna be in the office and I want
people to do what they enjoy doing I
don't want I want to find out what they
actually want where they want to go and
then and then and then make that happen
absolutely and I think that sometimes
people apply for a job and they didn't
think it is well they thought it was
something different to what actually it
turns out to be so do you have
mechanisms by which you can - two
questions here a promote people
internally
and be can people move around from
department to department if they feel
they're not quite in the right space
absolutely we yes to both questions and
I think some of our people have been in
one role and then after a few months
they're not loving it you know all all
they're just think you know this isn't
really what I thought it would be and
we've moved them into a completely
different role we've we've had people
who have been in admin and they're
really fond then it boring and then
they've moved over to customer service
or they've moved over to being a
training advisor or whatever it might be
and I think that is one of the massive
perks about a company cos normal if you
don't like your job you have to then go
and find another job in another company
but for us you don't want your job okay
well what job do you want to do yeah and
then they can just apply for another job
within the company it is to be
completely different yeah so that that's
actually something that we I encourage
that yeah because if someone's not happy
I mean we just did it wasn't that they
weren't even happy but theirs and the
Amelia who was a videographer and I went
around the room of all the videographers
we've got six and I said to each
videographer what do you enjoy most
about your job like what are you most
excited about and everyone said you know
oh I like making little trailers and
there's someone else who said I like
going out on the road and doing
documentaries someone else would say I
like putting all the text and the music
and all that over it and then it got to
Amelia and she didn't actually have much
to say about videography she was just
like I kind of like working with
influencers and help him find cool
things and thinking up ideas for the
YouTube channel she didn't and I
thinking that's not really videography
that's not now she's talent manager
there was no talent manager we made up
the title for her she created her own
job because she was like wasn't she was
dead good decent videographer you know
good I'm not knocking two videography
skills some of the guys are like
absolute expert videographers they love
it they are obsessed with it and they
want to be where was with her is like
yeah man I enjoy video and I'm kind of a
bit self-taught but now she's talent
manager she created the job role with me
herself so she's now going out working
with influencers finding celebrities
bringing people onto the YouTube channel
working with our success students and
our guests
putting dinners on it's just a deep
totally different role she loves it she
loves it and it suits us go sir yeah but
but I love that and if and if someone's
I'm very open to suggestions if
someone's like you know what hey I think
that this would be a good thing like we
we are very open for that kind of stuff
and I used to think like I used to look
at McDonald's I managed to see
McDonald's and think the way they
operate they have very average people in
McDonald's you know 16 year old kids
giving burgers with extraordinary
systems yeah and all I used to think
right as a businessman I want to create
these extraordinary systems and then I'm
just gonna get normal people to come and
run the systems that's the way to run a
business I've totally changed my mind on
that I don't know I can't speak on
behalf of my parents I mean jeez
now I'm thinking number one who do I
think I am able to make extraordinarily
need is we need extraordinary people to
come into the company and then help us
put together those extraordinary systems
and probably if you look at McDonald's
at the top we see the the people giving
the burgers now but I'm sure they've got
extraordinary people at the top and now
we're a growing company so now we're
just looking for talent we're looking
for extraordinary people people that can
potentially even create a new job role
create a new manual create a new and and
I just a sec sign yoga recruiting right
now right yeah we're quitting we recruit
yeah how other than paying people a
salary how do you reward success in the
company for individual employees so we
have lots of different ways we reward
people so we reward people I guess
financially it's probably the most
common way so we give people bonuses we
have a team bonus so if the team hits
their monthly target and even if that's
the case of you know it for instance in
the media team if they put all the
videos up every day at the right time
and they put the right amount of content
out and then there's a monthly bonus
then there's also weekly bonuses what's
that to incentivize I think it's just
because it just creates a sense of
almost positive peer pressure
so if someone messes up the others are
like ah come on so that that's and it
might might have some negative
connotations there's no perfect system
there's no perfect business so here we
have things like that and then also I
guess just promotions recognition the
recognition do you have something like
employee yes we do we have Employee of
the Month every month someone wins the
Employee of the Month and people go
crazy you know for the employer employee
of the month we do have that I think
recognition is really really important
without naming names because that person
might be very shy can you remember which
department won the Employee of the Month
yes last Employee of the Month was
someone in our finance team and a month
before the month before was customer
service before that do you remember
training advisor well done you you
really are on top of everything the
finance team are amazing really really
good yeah do you mentor staff personally
yes I do how do you do that many
different ways so I'll sit with us I
trained them in a group in groups so
I'll sit with you I'll sit with the
training advisers I'll sit with a sales
team I'll sit with the with the media
team and spend maybe a half day just
training them that's what I am I'm a
trainer we have a property company and a
training company so massively into that
we also send them off on lots of
training courses and we have we have
in-house training video courses and
stuff which they do every single day
every single day that they're being
trained yeah I also personally as well
as doing training as groups I also do
things like I'll give people feedback so
if someone's done something great I'll
tell them why it was great and how it
could have been better sit with people
one-on-one take people out for ad hoc
coffees and stuff and just say hey how's
it going and see where they're
struggling with and I'm a training
company and if we want the company to
grow up our people have to grow
and what quote the Richard Branson says
which I absolutely love is train your
staff so well that they can leave but
treat them so well they don't see I
think that is for me I love and I think
that will be the case every member of
staff or at least I think so most will
get to a point if they're not there
already some of them are there already
some of them are there early they'll get
to the point where they're so good
they're gonna be poached by so many
people like I mean Gary Vaynerchuk his
videographer he's called d-roc he's
almost famous for just being an awesome
videographer he works full time for Gary
Vaynerchuk he must care he must get
every day people saying to him can you
work for me can you work for me can you
work for me I bet people offer him more
money than Gary pays him like he must
get there so often but I don't think
he'd ever leave Gary because Gary
trained him he's loyal to Gary he loves
working with Gary and I think even with
that company you know it's already it
already is happening and it will happen
more people will be coming to our guys
you know can you can you come work for
us in fact yeah it's happened a lot
actually but it doesn't usually work out
if it does because people leave and then
they realize oh man I got paid an extra
few thousand pounds but this is pretty
rubbish compared but I I want people to
have that freedom and have that choice
and if they if they leave great but
treat them so well they don't want to
but I love training I love training them
and I love seeing personal growth one of
the things that excites me more than
anything is seeing people get better
seeing people seeing people get better
seeing their people skills get better
their confidence get better so many
people come to more of the company and
within a month they're like I'm a
different person I'm so much more
confident I love life more unhappier
where skills are better and we've spent
hundreds of thousands of pounds on
training our staff on top of hours and
hours of time every week yeah I can
testify that people have actually said
that
to me that that working for you has
changed their lives and that they feel
so much more energized that they feel
that they've learned so much in such a
short period of time yeah but that's all
very well when things are going right
when things are going well with
everything's hunky-dory what do you do
to support staff when things go wrong
so either professionally or when things
go wrong for them personally so I guess
it depends on what it is you know if
someone's going through a rough time I
do think we're a compassionate company
we have grace on people if someone's you
know had a personal issue or not Wow or
whatever
generally the heart that company is not
well what can we what can we legally get
away with you know we are compassionate
I mean we had one guy in the company he
was diagnosed with cancer and this was
known going back a couple of years and I
mean I personally just said to him dude
he's going for treatment take as much
time off as you need and we'll just keep
laying aside and he had all his
treatment and he actually got the he got
the all-clear I think he was like maybe
six or nine months he had off and then
he came back and I just said to him I
don't want you to worry about money
during this time now I'm not saying that
every time someone sick will do that
because you can't you can't do that and
a lot of people unfortunately war take
advantage but I knew this guy he was a
good guy and he knew that a new issue I
knew his circumstances and I think that
even if at times we do have to you can't
always but I think my heart is just to
look after people yeah so and then
professionally how do we how do we I
guess if someone's if someone's not not
performing professionally the first
thing is to just offer them offer them
some of them support see how they can
improve see if we maybe we can move to a
different Department someone's got a
good attitude
even if professionally their skills are
like they're not curling it but their
heart is in the right clients and that
attitude is good I don't think we've
ever let anything go for their
professional skills if they've been
clumsy or they've they'd forgetful and
it's like man you just cannot be in this
role but their hearts in the right place
then we'll just move them to a different
role which suits them all my
so everything is messy at times but
that's what I was going to say because
what I'm getting at is to say
something's happened let's say you're
running in events you run up training
and something's happens and it's
affected the team because somebody
hasn't quite done the right thing or as
a team things didn't smoothly and you're
not obsess about it as such but
something's gone wrong yeah and there's
a bunch of people you don't know who it
is you don't know what happened but you
know something's gone wrong how would
you approach that situation would you go
would you flip out and go mad or what
what would you do you found out that
something went wrong and I didn't say
people weren't books on the course when
they should have been I'm not saying
that has happened but as a as a theory
I'd want to find out I'd want to fix the
system and ultimately take
responsibility as a leader and say well
maybe I didn't I didn't know we didn't
as a company train them well enough you
know ultimately even if someone's really
bad and it's their fault then you
shouldn't have hired them in the first
place yeah so ultimately I'd like to
think that I take responsibility for
everything that goes wrong and just try
and fix it but yeah it is a problem you
just got to find out there will be
problems will be problem exactly it's
problems always know I just won't fix
one fix what happened if the person if
it was if it was complete foolish of the
person and and they were very
irresponsible and they were at fault and
you might have to you know give them a
give them a warning or something but
yeah it's very rare that somebody's
going to do something bad on purpose
yeah right so very often people have
done something because yeah would you
consider yourself a generous company I
think so I mean we pack we but we do pay
we do pay guys pretty well okay you know
everyone everyone's paid well I'm
personally a lot of employers a lot oh
my gosh they're trying to lift the
minimum wage they're trying to lift the
minimum wage and I'm thinking yeah and
they should I mean I'm I want I want
people to get paid well
I think I don't know what the lowest
were the lowest guys are paid but I
think we're generous generally I'm not
just talking about oh yeah we pay
everyone a big fat paycheck we pay
everybody well it was paid well
everyone's paid a bit like above we like
to look at how can our competitors and
Steffan pay more but but but not just
generous in terms of finances but also
generous in terms of opportunity also
generous in terms of training and time
like I've spent 10,000 pounds and I've
got a guy doing some training of some of
the team only six people I've paid ten
thousand pounds over this weekend for
six people to get some training but and
for us that as a company house just was
just nothing so soon as people come and
they say oh you know oh I'm gonna I'm in
finance and then they want to go and get
further qualified and I'm always in
favor of my company just paying for that
mm-hmm because so there's no vesting in
people I think yeah I think we're not
stupid no I think I would agree I think
what I seen is very generous very
generous company you're you are all
there for people's growth which i think
is great and then talking of donor ah
city are you having a Christmas party
this year yes I don't know when but it
is being organised you know let's talk
about it are you it's top secret top
secret surprise surprise well I hope you
have a wonderful time
thanks so much happy Christmas in
advance happy Christmas to you too
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you